é so jornais
agora sim tá tá tá bom né é tem 23 anos
sou natural milhões que é uma lei
potencia a água só vez a competência de
31 anos é a minha saída é que em caso de
saída na volta ele pra mim não dá mais
pra mim isso é muito bom o real tinha
escrito nem se numa seqüência que a
gente fazer uma língua só fazemos 52
novos policiais nessa boneca que é uma
coisa de verão é um é meu diz que tal
ensaio será um curso e um workshop terá
coragem e foi uma coisa que pensar
porque o prefeito jorge freitas
[Música]
só assim pra morar no chão disse e foi
uma das páginas dos principais é ganhar
um novo emprego ele estava agora disse
não vou ajudar o movimento cruzer vezes
contêm fibras média tinha uma casa
branca pra casa seria uma taxa de r 50
quero poder ajudar os meus personagens
nos quais ganhou o euro foi fazer uma
coisa que não gostam dele é maior já que
fiz eu ensino superior sejam ou não eu
gostava guerra muito intensa porquê foi
um carro só que não é maneira dele
trabalhar com o irmão de 9 anos não se
mostrava obviamente eu fazia 2 a 0 em
salvador
pra mim é de viseu
é ela a compra do material e imaterial
material acaba sendo bastante caro e eu
não tenho possibilidades para eu comprar
então o pai deles encontrava estável
é de novo é a comprar eu fiquei olha a 5
prova e ele tiver o experimento amigos
turismo horário o lugar na semana
seguinte vai junto
eu vou trabalhar no país homem mais
tarde de sábado para comprar todo o
material eu não aceitam porque era uma
coisa que eu realmente estava bastante
que é uma coisa que era uma coisa que eu
tenho hoje
[Música]
hoje eu consegui mudar não só maneira
perdeu a mãe também como muitas outras
pessoas conseguiram mudar a maneira em
que não é só uma coisa é uma coisa é
ouvir uma coisa é é simplesmente
simplesmente encara como aplicar como a
minha profissão e tem todos os dias como
valão mais longe possível não só por mim
mas também por todos nós porque é
importante no não diferenciar ninguém
perceba que somos cada um veste de
maneira quer que eu não gostava nem de
estar na vida e acho que nós todos nós
temos que ter respeito para com todos os
outros e e isso eu tenho tentado fazer
com que o trabalho vá o mais longe
possível e também ao mesmo tempo consiga
conseguir limpar certas mentalidades que
ainda existem antigas e acho que com o
tempo a ser tão a ser usuários de ambos
foi um caso sequer também foi a primeira
vez já falou para tanta gente é sempre
novo sismo inicial eu já estou a ficar
mais
mais tranqüilo o microfone então parece
que houve duas vozes
ok é como a informação tinha uma
disciplina por fazer esse trabalho que
conseguiu ser
tão grande que eu tive que deixar essas
conhecer e ponderar disciplina o meu
trabalho como era uma coisa que eu fazia
por gosto e tava ver dentro daquilo que
fazia uma possível profissão é possível
isto é eu inicialmente físico como homem
para conseguir pagar algumas despesas e
de um momento para o outro em muito
pouco tempo eu percebi que podia ser a
minha profissão anos de profissão de
sony e uma paixão pra mim o que é atuar
de hoje pra mim considera a tatuagem
como uma paixão e com o sony
continuassem mostrando estar à espera
que seja por muito tempo na minha
profissão ou quem sabe até o final da
minha vida não sei porque é mesmo que eu
gosto de fazer e e espera espera uma
tela é sempre presente é profissão na
minha vida pronto quando 18 anos vai se
arrastar eu sei eu te encontrar
foi muito fácil pra mim deixei de fazer
hoje é obviamente estava a ter o 12º
andar concluída
sei que nunca é tarde para concluir e
fazer a qualquer momento
viveu o chef trabalhou e viveu há o
trabalho que eu tenho eu sei que não
será fácil trair que a música certamente
[Música]
parte do trabalho mas não sei se o
faturamento foi leonel trabalho foi tão
grande que eu abri é conseguir um
monstro com o dinheiro o dinheiro que eu
ia juntando que ganha confiança e
mostrou lhe tentava é já e conseguir
trazer pessoas que me faltava que acaba
por ser uma vila muito grande conseguir
trazer a pessoa já muito muito alto como
coimbra recebe pessoas dizer o pessoal
da newsweb hospital pessoas selado levou
mesmo assim já trazia pessoas de alguns
quilômetros a distância até mim com com
18 anos é passar um tempo é um convite
que recebi um convite
quando o estúdio um convidado a
trabalhar como todo profissional é oa e
então é eu como sou só eu que gosto da
galera todas as unidades que são dadas
nos gostos primeiro filho é agarrá la de
que foi alvo que problema hoje não quer
saber aquilo que elas podiam andar
então eu ganhasse o filme vá mas antes
de chegar a essa idade eu já tive um
convite da parte do pedro para mais
tarde talvez viajar para viseu uma
pessoa de palavra o pedro exatamente a
mesma coisa é combinamos então é eu ir
seria uma coisa vou a pé e eu preciso
não só como como artista como também
como pessoa é e depois quando estivesse
confortável e se achasse que devia vir
para viseu a gente conversar ia e e eu
venho trabalhar para viseu
já fui com um convite já tinham tido um
convite aceitei e já fui com um outro
convite a outra possibilidade de
trabalho
caso as coisas não corressem bem e foi o
que acabou por acontecer em meio ano na
suíça trabalhares né
eu não falava a língua da minha família
estava longe dos meus amigos está longe
de tudo é ver as condições em que vive
não era assim tão boas quanto isto fui
não fui ouvir foi nem foi enganado e foi
na minha na minha consciência que
simplesmente ganhar aquela primeira
seria certamente boa pra mim foi uma
unidade do outro que em vários aspectos
não só começou como tatuador como como
vivi coisas que jamais pensei viver
foi uma fase muito complicada para mim
porque estava longe de tudo o que tinha
uma pessoa com quem desabafar não
tenhamos mais perto de mim não tem
nenhum nome para o time com quem pudesse
gostar de alimento era um cara do casa
trabalho trabalho casa casa trabalho
trabalho casa
claro que o trabalho é uma coisa que eu
gosto de fazer mas todos nós queremos
ter um tempinho para desabafar para
falar para para conseguir e conseguimos
é um enviado de certa forma nós três
looks fizer um ritmo de trabalho caso a
casa trabalha acaba por ser muito
e esse é que elas têm muito carinho para
ti é mandar mensagem por pedro dizer
pedro olha tá na altura o pedro é desde
logo olha quando achar melhor então a
gente vai combinar é veio trabalhar para
viseu
e assim foi aceitar eu aceitei logo olha
estou muito interessado em ir a viseu
não sinto brincar o perdedor veja as
portas abertas vamos fazer as coisas que
me deixes vencer eu já tenho imagem de
cerca de três meses e 14 lá eu comprei
um trabalho que tinha lá um obviamente
não deixei nada para fazer e trabalhar
para pagar empresa torto hoje toda a
gente conhece é uma das melhores
empresas de tatuagem nível da europa e é
melhor portugal quem é pirata texto já
que em viseu que acho que muitos de vós
já ouviram falar e certamente há muito
você joga não falaram com a gente aqui
espero eu
e já há quase três anos
pronto durante este tempo todo é eu
tenho e tenho conseguido levar o
trabalho a muitas partes do mundo do
gênero já vai trabalhar e nunca pensei
que poderia provar diariamente todas as
partes da suíça frança uma em londres
enquanto qualquer parte da inglaterra
angola já não só eu como os colegas de
cela phillip nem outra tudo que se possa
imaginar a gente estados unidos o
argumento que cada vez mais vem então
hoje fazer tantos quilômetros para
trabalhar não só comigo como outros
colegas que trabalham comigo do gênero
23 já estamos há 23 anos extremamente
motivo de orgulho conseguir movimentar
pessoas de tão longe
o fato de eu tenho que pagar viagens tão
caras o fato terem pagado do hotéis
o facto de jardim 16 18 20 e 10 horas
sei lá é muito gratificante é sem dúvida
tive orgulho para mim e vejo isso com ou
sem dúvida um uma força maior uma força
uma força que me faz crer mais crescer
mais e levar o mais possível ainda mais
longe o que o meu trabalho é durante
esse tempo todo é eu tenho viajado muito
e tatuagem tem proporcionado coisas
muito boas coisas que também não não
jamais imaginei viver como disse já
anteriormente
é eu viajo muito claramente que era ver
se ele viajar mais
o fato de viajar e de querer aprender
mais tem feito com que eu chego essas
pessoas que vêm de fora com isso consigo
ver um bom trabalho fora então as
pessoas começam a conhecer mais o meu
trabalho eu já consegui viajar pra muito
chique para multidões mesmo era ver se
consigo mais
já participa em várias convenções
internacionais e nacionais em que em
portugal e destas convenções já consiga
distinguir neste momento já conta com 16
17 prêmios nacionais e internacionais
das quais eu são bastante bastante
importante
vamos agora mostrar alguns dos trabalhos
é trabalho é um pouco do meu potencial e
sei lá eu tenho imenso trabalho trabalho
de diversificadas e vou só deixará
alguns dos meus trabalhos ao longo desta
vez que o percurso também já consegui
trabalhar com pessoas ligadas ao futebol
com figuras públicas ligadas ao futebol
e com figuras públicas ligadas à música
e muitas outras pessoas também todos os
ramos e de outras profissões trabalho
trabalho e trabalho por exemplo foi
premiado em paris na convenção numa numa
da sociedade é para com alunos é melhor
comer são tatuagens da europa na forma
tentada uma convenção que entrou perto
de 50 mil pessoas visitantes durante
três dias de evento
e é sem dúvida motivo o dog pra mim não
são pequenos detalhes que eu faço entre
o mundo mostrou fria mesmo preto e
cinzento
as pessoas procuram especialmente por
isto esta tatuagem também foi premiada
em parisi não passar
pronto isto é o que realmente gosta de
fazer e e todos os dias quando quando
ele o trabalho tento inovar e
revolucionar a vida cada vez mais um
mandato e fazendo com que eu seja o meu
movimento da arte
a sad encarnada pelas pessoas como uma
uma tel aviv ganhamos porque o foco
esteve a já então hoje mas seja a sua
viagem de 20 horas semanais ou criar uma
hora para trabalhar comigo eu respeito
respeito ao máximo cada segundo que ela
sempre buscamos gastão comigo
sem dúvida é tatuagem é é das poucas
arte ou a única artista das poucas a
escola que pintura de tudo ficam sempre
guardadas e registadas mas a tatuagem é
uma coisa que vai pra toda a vida com
pessoas não é bem feita é feita é mal
feita é muito mais complicado reverter e
e melhorar tudo isso e o fato tem que
ser como vida que não é tão fácil quanto
as pessoas imaginam não há nada que
demova 100% mal feita e é isso emprega
em queda segundo o trabalho em apenas
uma das pessoas que viajam para cá
comigo em queda sendo que elas gastam em
viagens comigo em viagens para consertar
até para chegar até mim e eu respeito
isso é o máximo e acho que é esse
respeito e emprega o meu trabalho é essa
a ambição e profissionalismo e se
escrever e escrever como o trabalho vá o
mais longe possível que faz com que este
sucesso ao longo do tempo este pequeno
sucesso pra mim eu quero muito mais do
que isto para mim isso é uma base de
tudo jamais consegui jamais imaginei
conseguir ficar aqui até aqui mas agora
estou aqui pra mim acaba por ser é um
caso fogo então seu poder se poderá
fazer mas eu quero fazer mais por isso
não é só bom pra mim como é bom pra
todos nós o fato já que em viseu
conseguimos trazer pessoas de todo mundo
até viseu
reparei consigo me movimentar muita
gente de todos os cantos do mundo até
dizer o que muita gente pergunta por quê
não tá no porto e em lisboa não temos
aeroportos hoje chega na hora porque não
tem jóia órgão cabe até viseu mas não as
pessoas querem mesmo trabalhar com a
gente
eheheheheh um motivo de orgulho mesmo
muito muito grande para nós poder
receber pessoas de todo mundo então tem
que respeitar ao máximo e esperamos
conseguir um bom trabalho e e
regressarem trazendo outros clientes
atrás mostrava algumas fotos já antigas
dos meus primeiros prêmios aqui foi em
2015 como podem ver foi o primeiro
presente que eu ganhei uma convenção
onde eu ainda trabalhava sozinho que
depois a convite do pedro eu acompanhei
isso dependem de jai tenha tenha um
pouco tempo tatuagem bastante protetor a
gente conseguiu ganhar um prêmio como
deixou o que o que me deixou bastante
motivado para que o que vem a ser isto é
foi mais quatro para enxergar nem na
edição é a seguir quando eu quando vi a
apnéia é importante é a piranha e levou
uma convenção passado oito dias choveu
passar uma semana tivemos uma correção
também no porto onde eu fui premiado com
quatro com quatro prédios onde ganhei a
minha tatuagem de um evento melhor ganha
duas vezes melhor pretense do evento é e
eu ganhei até nova ordem do dia também
foi quatro prêmios que conseguir guardar
esta foi outro prêmio que ganhei em
paris foi uma tatuagem que deu bastante
gosto fazer porque representa um caso de
ilusão com passagem até papel é bastante
para mim é um desafio bastante bastante
complicado porque às vezes
hoje ele perceber como é que vê como é
que eu consegui fazer é pequenos
pormenores contam e mexe o resultado
final da tatuagem foi bastante positivo
e confiar cada um dos prêmios durante
muitos e artista também fala de um
evento que leva 420 artista
isso não precisa como 30 está o terceiro
melhor
este foi no ano passado com a parte
frontal que eu fiz 11 um cliente e amigo
meu é conseguir ganhar o melhor prêmio
preta e cinza grande vai ser bastante
motivado e bastante motivado e orgulhoso
também mais tarde
ganhei esse prêmio em veneza e como os
dis já consegui chegar até figuras
públicas não é que faça isso de mim é
mais o melhor que alguém não não tem
nada a ver com isso tem simplesmente a
ver com o que eu graças a deus estou
confiante se a área é pessoas como estas
que são pessoas nem mais nem menos
qualquer outra como sei que estão aqui
são pessoas que me ajuda de certa forma
é considerado fácil já trazer outras
pessoas porque são pessoas muito
seguidas de alimentos a pessoas que são
vistas diariamente que consigo em salvar
o meu trabalho mais longe também graças
ao poder trabalhar com ela está curada
agora vez que já teve no benfica agora
está no manchester city inglaterra
também tentou então isca tua vila eo
lisandro lópez que agora não está nem
fiquei da mãe
o ataque do porto o salvio benfica
o alex tels
agora uma amizade hoje também lançou um
clipe como tamanho amigo é o juízo é
algumas vezes é um pouco alguns dos
momentos que guardo comigo que eu possa
mostrar aqui através das minhas redes
sociais consiga mostrar muito mais são
apenas algumas fotos que eu tenho comigo
fotos telemóvel que o pouco ou nada
agora nesse momento mas alguns momentos
especiais para mim esse é um momento
importante da minha carreira
pronto para finalizar eu penso que eu
sei que briguei muito isso aqui que a
gente sabe
fica muita coisa para dizer eu sei que o
tempo também é encarada curto mas isso
também é como disse minha primeira vez
que eu falei para tantas pessoas já
havia me é mas acho que tudo tem começo
se tem um porquê e hoje foi o começou a
falar às pessoas para que ter o convite
a outras coisas também futuramente mas
eu penso que tanto eu como qualquer
outra tem aqui presente hoje como todas
as pessoas algumas das pessoas que estão
na platéia é e hoje somos pessoas
conseguimos evoluir dentro daquilo que
fazemos toda por todo o porto pro
arriscar porque acha que é preciso eu
acho que as pessoas que têm consegue ter
um pouco sucesso hoje é acho que tem a
ver com a arriscar
acho que qualquer pessoa tem sucesso
aqui e que está aqui por exemplo à risca
foi fundamental para que o riscar a
ambição o creme muito uma coisa acho que
foi sem dúvida é o papel fundamental
para conseguir ser a opção hoje e como
está a dizer qualquer operadora e voz e
as pessoas estão na planta e hoje somos
pessoas e na área por tudo por tudo isso
e é por isso que estamos aqui hoje é
falar um pouco de 9 e passar um pouco da
nossa experiência é não querendo deixar
que só o senhor que este é um trabalho
de muitas horas é um trabalho de muita
dedicação são trabalhos de 11 horas por
dia
muita coisa muda muito pois tem muitas
coisas para fazer muito
às vezes o creio eu eo ea missão e o
sono é tão grande que deixamos um parte
da nossa vida parte de coisa por fazer
viárias para conseguirmos um trabalho de
cinco horas não seja igual a um trabalho
do verso e acho que o trabalho delas
consegue ser mais que foi só com
trabalho assim que eu quero no meu
trabalho é trabalhar ao invés de deixar
uma coisa bem feita para toda a vida eu
vou trabalhar sempre pra ficar uma coisa
não tão bem feita
porque é isso que o distingue hoje e é
por isso também estou aqui é para tirar
um pouco da experiência que vocês também
muito obrigado e desculpem qualquer erro
da minha parte